I'm Robert Hassler and I'm from  southlake texas i graduated from  covenant christian academy in 2011 i'm  now a senior at Hillsdale College  majoring in financial management I work  downtown at valente an associate's part  of the Washington Hillsdale internship  program the Washington Hillsdale  internship program we call a whip for  short we bring anywhere between 10 to 20  students a semester out to DC they take  two or three classes and they in turn on  the hill at the Heritage Foundation  really anywhere they want to we find  somebody coming out of college who has  some practical real-world experience  especially experience that applies to  what we do it really sets them apart  Washington is one of those places that  kids can learn a lot and gain a lot just  from being here for a few months and  that sense coming here and having that  internship experience i can guarantee  will be life-changing